welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is Eric Trexler I am the
special temporary primary host for
today's episode I'm going to be joined
by Greg Knuckles he is currently the
permanent guest co-host for the time
being Greg thanks for joining me thanks
for having me on how are you doing you
know what I'll I'll be completely honest
with with you and the listeners this is
why I stopped asking I'm not I'm not
doing my best today uh yesterday my wife
and I got both our covet booster and our
flu shot for the year the thinking
behind that was uh historically they've
had very different effects on me so uh
covet booster makes me feel kind of achy
sluggish tired and flu shots I don't
think this is a common thing but for
whatever reason uh flu shots just make
me feel extremely wired
um as if they're like a super powerful
stimulant I guess like just just
Limitless amounts of nervous energy
which which I guess is just like my
immune system just kind of like picking
up my my sympathetic nervous system to
be like ah like it's it's time to fight
something whatever so very different uh
historical uh effects of those two
vaccines so I was thinking like oh well
if I just knock him out on the same day
maybe it'll just like more or less
cancel each other out you know
um take an upper and a downer yeah yeah
pretty much yeah instead it turns out it
turned out to be the worst of Both
Worlds
um very sluggish very achy felt like I
got hit by a truck but then also like
couldn't sleep yeah um so I feel like I
got run over by a truck today and I am
not at my best uh but I will try to pull
things together and make for at least a
tolerable episode for for both you and
the audience
over under of comments we get about
covid and vaccines uh well
where are we setting the betting line
it's going to be a lower number than it
was initially going to be
um I had just just a lot of jokes and
bits planned about that but as I
understand it uh
certain podcast platforms are very
sensitive about that kind of stuff and
don't do a good job of of uh
telling apart sarcastic jokes from
sincerely held beliefs so uh yeah yeah
so I I think I don't know I I think
we'll probably get
I I'd put the over under at like 12
maybe yeah I actually I think I will
take the under if we're saying discreet
comments and not including follow-ups
I'll take the under on that do you read
the YouTube comments I don't okay
uh well in this case I am I'm like the
house I'm like the Vegas casino that has
access to maybe a little bit more inside
information than all of the Bettors do
and uh we we will see all right yeah
time will tell
um how how are uh how are you doing
today I'm good good yeah no complaints
um let's get into it here let's do it if
you like the show
um I have no way of knowing because I
don't read the YouTube comments uh but
if you like it uh there are ways that
you could support it you could like rate
or subscribe wherever you happen to get
the podcast uh as I mentioned last week
you could sign up for the email
newsletter uh we send out weekly emails
with really useful research updates uh
and to find out more about that or sign
up for free you can go to
strongerbyscience.com newsletter
if you're looking for a one-on-one coach
who works in a virtual capacity looking
for some online coaching we do offer
that we have a very talented and
experienced team of coaches you can
learn more about that at
strongerbyscience.com coaching uh if you
are looking for a little discount on
your supplements or I should probably
say a massive discount on your
supplements go to bulksupplements.com
you can use our code SBS pod SBS pod
that will get you a five percent
discount off your entire order and of
course if you want to support us further
you can check out the mass research
review which we publish every single
month the first of the month reviewing
all the newest research and exercise and
nutrition and some miscellaneous topics
I've been doing a little stuff on
psychology and coaching and things like
that and you could also check out macro
Factor that's the uh the diet app that
we co-developed with a very talented
team of developers and you we do have a
free trial so you can uh you know give
it a shot take it for a spin and see if
you like it before you commit
financially
uh now before we get into our prepared
segments a little bit of chatter here uh
on the show in the past we've talked a
little bit about
academic publishing or scientific
publishing
um I would say in some cases we've been
critical of the the process and there's
a new kind of publication model I it
seems new to me I haven't seen any like
major high profile journals try this yet
but it was just announced like a day or
two ago and so my Twitter which is
carefully cultivated you know
everybody's talking about it in my
Twitter timeline so a journal called
E-Life is really changing the way they
do it so normally uh you know you'll
submit a paper to a journal and the
editor will take a look at it and if the
editor is like hey this is just crap
they'll just send it back and say like
hey I'm not going to send that out to to
peer reviewers or if they simply decide
you know what I think this is good work
but it just doesn't really make sense in
our Journal it's just way too off topic
for what we focus on so great work but
you might want to take it elsewhere
again it'll just go straight back to the
author the editor makes the first choice
of saying okay this is good enough and
it's a decent fit for our Journal I'm
going to seek out peer reviewers who are
going to critique it weigh in and then
ultimately the peer reviewers give a
recommendation to the editor something
that's kind of interesting is
theoretically there's nothing stopping
an editor if both if if the editor if he
or she sends it out to multiple
reviewers and all the reviewers say this
sucks this is the dumbest thing I've
ever read it's a fabricated fraudulent
this is just absolutely terrible work in
every possible way technically the
editor still makes the call you can just
say like I liked it yeah but generally
speaking the editor uh takes the
recommendations from the reviewers very
seriously
and in most cases if the reviewers can't
really come to a consensus you know that
then you know the editor tries to reach
a consensus and ultimately uh make a
judgment that is compatible with the
reviews and that the editor decides
either we're going to accept this paper
and publish it or reject it hand it back
to the author and say do whatever you
want with it so this new model uh the
spin that they're taking here is the
editor is still going to do that first
line of kind of editorial judgment where
they say okay yeah this looks pretty
good good enough for a review and I
think it kind of works for our Journal
once they decide to send it to reviewers
E-Life is now committed to publishing
that paper but they are not making any
decisions about accepting or rejecting
the paper so basically what they're
going to do is publish the paper with a
lot of transparency about what the
reviewers thought about it so
theoretically you could they could be
hosting a paper that is technically
published on their site that is just
absolutely Dreadful and all the reviews
are quite negative
um so what they're doing is they're
turning it away from a dichotomous
decision of this is excellent perfect
science or not excellent perfect science
and they're making it more of a type of
thing where it's like here's an article
here's what some reviewers think and
it's a little bit more fluid a little
bit more there's more gradation there in
terms of each individual uh research or
whoever's reading it kind of making an
assessment of all right how good was
this and and what is some uh content
experts think about it so uh it's really
an interesting idea and I think it's
really cool and I'm I'm pretty on board
I don't I don't think it's like a a
silver bullet I don't think it's the
perfect thing that's going to
revolutionize publishing for the better
for the better but I'm generally
interested in breaking up the inertia in
the academic publishing
infrastructure and process I'm
interested in more uh Avenues to
publication that are dramatically
different from the status quo because I
think if we try a few different
iterations at the very least we'll get
out of this really rigid kind of single
approach to publishing so I think it's
really cool and one of the things that
um I've seen a lot of good takes about
this on the internet and a lot of bad
takes about it in my opinion one of the
things that's really interesting is
there seems to be a misconception about
why editors offloaded a lot of the
decision making to reviewers in the
first place that there seems to be a
misunderstanding of the historical
evolution of that process so I I saw
somebody posted
um I'm gonna link to this in the show
notes but it was kind of a historical
look at how this came to be and much to
my surprise I genuinely didn't know this
um for a long time there up until like
the 60s and 70s it pretty much was just
that the editors called the shots and a
lot of the
um reviewing process was handled
in-house by the Journal they weren't
just like fishing it around and like
emailing people like hey I need to go
you know track down two or three folks
to review this where's my list of
reviewers it was very much the journal
uh made editorial decisions in-house and
didn't rely on external peer reviews
um if they did it was not as commonplace
as it is today but uh according to the
uh the thing I'm linking in the show
notes Here it says that uh basically
um
the journals just said like hey this is
kind of a lot like we're just kind of
struggling to keep up with this
um we need to lighten our workload on
the editorial side and doing all of this
ourselves is very cumbersome and so um
they also said that you know this is not
what they call Pleasant or satisfying
work they're like we just don't want to
do this anymore yeah um and so the the
bad take that I've been seeing is this
assumption that the the way the peer
review process currently Works was
established because it safeguards
quality and was made for you know the
decision-making process was just driven
by we need to make sure that we have the
most rigorous processes in place and
this ensures the highest degree of rigor
and if we buy pre bypass this typical
process there's no way that we could
possibly Safeguard the uh the quality of
the you know the peer-reviewed
literature or the scientific literature
and it's and I mean one thing I'll note
is there others an assumption that I
think most people very reasonably make
which is you know since this is about
scientific publishing after all if the
if the publication model changes and the
mechanism by which papers are accepted
or rejected from the journal's changes
I think it's a perfectly reasonable
assumption to just assume that some
scientists did some science and made
sure that the new system worked better
than the old system
um but that simply didn't happen they
they just moved to a a peer review
focused system for a variety of other
reasons right and there was also um a
former editor-in-chief was it the
British Journal of Medicine yeah it was
bmj I think the the title of the paper
was peer review a flawed process at the
heart of Science and journals I I can
find it real quick yeah but but there
was basically
it sounds kind of silly when you put it
this way but the peer-reviewed
literature suggests that peer review is
pretty not great uh it does not live up
to the kind of agreed upon expectations
in terms of quality and rigor uh and
yeah like peer-reviewed research has
been carried out to see how good is peer
review and it doesn't really provide the
level of uh quality control that a lot
of people are indicating in this
conversation yeah uh and by the way just
to give credit where credit's due the
the thing I Linked In the show notes
that was talking about the historical
context of this process it was called uh
it's a a journal article called
scientific autonomy public
accountability and the rise of peer
review in the Cold War United States by
Melinda Baldwin
uh yes I have not read that article yet
I'm going to to put something else in
the show notes to be linked
um it's a article from 2018 on it's an
interview on just more of a uh
non-academic but therefore like more
readable platform from uh from a guy
named Robert Harrington
um which is also a pretty good history
of peer review I will note I'm a little
bit offended that uh you noted that you
weren't aware of some of the history of
peer review uh prior to this because I I
think I did a segment on the podcast
about it before well I was not aware of
the explicit admission from journals
that they started Outsourcing reviews
simply because they didn't feel like
doing oh yeah doing it anymore no that
that's fair
um one of the other one of the other big
factors at least in the U.S in
so one of the things that's kind of
um
like almost universally accepted is just
that peer review is a very good system
um
which
like I said the the research or like you
said the research tends to suggest that
it's not that good of a system so then
then the question is like how did we get
it in our ideas or like how did we get
it in our heads in the first place that
it did work really really well
um and it seems to mostly be like a
marketing campaign by scientists which
is very impressive because I I would
just assume most scientists aren't great
at marketing
um
but like one of the one of the steps
along that history was uh in the U.S
during the recession in the 70s like
during the stagflation era
um
uh people in Congress and the Senate
started reviewing projects that the NF
that the NSF the National Science
Foundation was funding and you you still
see this discourse today like they'll
look and see some of the projects
getting funded and be like ah like this
is frivolous this is a waste of taxpayer
dollars etc etc
um we need to cut funding to the NSF or
uh in the case of the 70s bring more of
that funding under congressional
oversight to make sure that uh I mean
since it was during the Cold War it was
like we need to make sure that the NSF
is funding projects that can help us
like blow up the ruskies if it comes to
that like that that was that was kind of
the vibe
um and the NSF was like [ __ ] that like
we we don't want we don't want
politicians like meddling in our funding
Like We Are Scientists we understand the
needs of the fields we cover better than
they do uh and so they like that's when
they shifted to a peer review model not
for not for publication but for grant
funding
um to basically say like look you want
more eyes on on the funding that the NSF
gives out but like we think other
scientists in this field will understand
that better than just like
random senators from you know random
states that don't know anything about
science uh and so they sold that to
Congress just as a way to get less
Congressional oversight and so in doing
so they had to to sell the process of
peer review for funding is like this is
this really good thing that we know
works really well and will definitely
work better than this like alternate
system you're proposing and and then
from there it kind of like trickled down
further into actual publication yeah
yeah I mean in terms of uh practical
tape takeaways from this uh for people
who are listening along I think there's
a couple things that come to mind
um one is that as people start exploring
these alternative publishing models like
just throwing something up on a
pre-print server or uh you know doing
this which is basically a pre-print with
comments uh from you know specifically
selected reviewers
um so when you start seeing these types
of papers you have you can't really
assume assume like oh this has been peer
reviewed and therefore it's correct
Counterpoint you probably never should
have assumed that in the first place yes
and I think that I think that if that
instills a little more doubt in people
that's ultimately a good thing right
yeah I mean I I saw a lot of chatter
that was saying well how can we just
blindly assume that all these papers are
rigorous and very good and I was like
were you doing that previously like why
like you're you're acting is so people
were like oh well these guys you know
people are just gonna publish papers
here so they can have a link and a DOI
and say look at this research I
published you know all my wacky ideas
are actually science
and that would make sense if it
literally didn't already happen but
exactly it absolutely already happens
within the normal peer review process I
mean if anything I think this is
preferable because the way it would work
now if you were trying to get dodgy
research published is you might try to
to slip it into a good journal in the
first place they send it out for peer
review maybe the peer reviewers do a
good job maybe you just get desk
rejected and ultimately the paper gets
rejected and you just need to move on to
some other Journal but the thing is
there are so many journals and and like
there are enough scammy journals that
are basically just pay to play that you
will be able to get that paper published
somewhere and generally like reviewer
comments in most journals aren't open
yet so as it is like it takes a little
bit more effort to get dodgy stuff
published but you absolutely can still
get it published and then you know it's
it's sitting there in PubMed without any
pushback with this model if you're
trying to get something dodgy published
well cool like it gets published right
off the bat and there are reviewer
letters attached to it saying like well
this is published but it's kind of
[ __ ] you know yeah so there there is
like within kind of that document itself
there there's pushback that wouldn't
exist otherwise yeah I mean ultimately I
think that this removes the automatic
credibility of a paper being published
and I struggle to see that as a bad
thing yeah I am all for that
um all right so moving on Greg you have
some hard-hitting signs to share as well
uh I do I do
um no this was just kind of a [ __ ] post
uh a a rugby strength coach on uh
Twitter tweeted a scatter plot uh
showing the the relationship between
bench press one rep max and uh number of
self-reported sexual partners I believe
and I could be wrong about this but I
believe I recognize this data set I
think this was a survey from the r
bodybuilding subreddit back in 2018 but
don't quote me on that I could be wrong
um but yeah no the the funny part about
it was just that uh there there was one
person with so most of the bench presses
were about what you'd expect some were
somewhere from the the like low to mid
hundreds in terms of pounds up to uh
like 300 350 you know the normal weights
that people bench press and within that
range it didn't seem like there was
really any relationship at all between
uh self-reported binge press Max and
self-reported uh number of sexual
partners but the funny thing was there
was one individual who bench pressed
more than a hundred pounds more than
anyone else uh they benched 450 and in
the next time
550 yeah yeah they bench press 550 and
the next highest was like looks like 4
30 maybe
um anyway that person reported no sexual
partners which is is just inherently
funny I think like that's a guy who's
really dedicated to his craft I I think
it's funny uh just because it almost
presents it's like uh what if an Excel
figure was actually an advertisement for
animal pack yeah yeah you know of just
the like oh my God just like in a
dungeon and being like Oh I'm so focused
on on this bench press that you know
it's it's the only thing in my mind
right now but to be clear we're not
trying to reinforce any narratives that
it's good or bad to have a high or low
number of sexual partners or anything
like that uh but but this kind of tweet
definitely uh fuels plenty of jokes
because there's kind of a a running joke
and a running stereotype that a lot of
young guys get into lifting and they're
really excited about how it's going to
have this huge impact on their dating
life and uh it it doesn't always go that
way absolutely I I think that I think
that doing a [ __ ] post review segment of
the podcast might be a new low for us
but I'm honestly completely fine with it
yeah all right uh speaking of a new low
we've got a couple great segments today
but before we do that we need to
shamelessly sell out so we're going to
take a quick timeout for an obscene
profit break
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than predicting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
I could not agree more the U.S Supreme
Court knows that corporations are people
and the team is stronger by science LLC
knows that corporations are some of the
most important people around that's why
I joined the Advisory board for the
Sports Nutrition Association Along with
trusted Fitness Pros like Danny Lennon
and distrusted arch nemesis like Eric
Helms that's good thinking Eric you
gotta keep your friends close and
enemies closer absolutely the Sports
Nutrition Association is the home of
Sports Nutrition they are dedicated to
ensuring the sustainable prosperity of
the Sports Nutrition profession and they
offer a unique Pathway to robust
insurance coverage for your Sports
Nutrition business simply put it's the
best way to protect the corporate
entities that are closest to your heart
and I should note if you're an
individual sole proprietor providing
Sports nutrition services and not a
corporate entity the Sports Nutrition
Association can help you out as well
that is correct all insurance plans are
handled individually on a case-by-case
basis regardless of how your Sports
Nutrition business is structured but
even if you don't want insurance
coverage sna membership comes with a
bunch of other perks and advantages the
Sports Nutrition Association is the only
Global professional sports body that has
a defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist with the
Sports Nutrition Association today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
alright so Greg uh your segment today
what do you have for us
uh yeah so I am talking about uh partial
range of motion training uh specifically
for strength so
um I partnered with Milo Wolff who uh
recently pre-printed a meta-analysis
examining uh the research looking at the
impact of range of motion on strength
development muscle growth uh Etc and we
have a very in-depth article that is
going to drop on November 1st I believe
this episode is going to be published in
full on the 31st so if if you're
listening to the full episode and not
one of the clips that gets posted on
YouTube beforehand that article will be
up tomorrow
um but I think most of the current
interest around this topic is related to
the impact of longer versus shorter
ranges of motion and training at longer
versus shorter muscle lengths on
hypertrophy but there is some some
pretty interesting research looking at
the effect of uh partial range of motion
training per se but more importantly
combining partial and in full range of
motion training for improving full range
of motion strength gains so that is what
this segment is going to be talking
about
um so Eric have you have you ever experi
experimented much with partial range of
motion training things like rack pulls
uh board press Etc yeah for sure what's
what's your uh what's your your current
Vibe around those training practices and
and what's what's your experience
um well back in the day a great way to
make my bench press seem higher was to
simply not go as low so that was my
first Venture into uh into limited range
of motion training uh no I my
perspective has been poisoned because
I've read all of the mass articles as a
reviewer of mass so I I'm kind of up to
speed with what the research shows but I
know like you know for me I when I was
you know back in the day before looking
into all the literature I would use
partial range of motion stuff for a
variety of different reasons I mean
sometimes if I was sometimes it's very
intuitive right so like I used to do
like you know uh various uh bench press
variations and you could tell when you'd
get that stretch at the bottom of the
rep you could really feel your pecs
stretching out I mean I would crank half
repetitions in that lengthen position
like crazy and just you know you feel
the burn and the pump and all that stuff
so even before looking looking at the
research it was very clear to me you
know there is something different here
to some extent about altering range of
motion so I I think partials partials on
bench on both sides of the spectrum are
really the biggest thing that I would
that I would do nice cool yeah I I'm in
a I'm in a similar boat uh used to do a
lot of pin press used to do a lot of
board press
um also really really enjoy block pulls
uh used to do a ton of rack pulls until
like
and until I I basically just got strong
enough that it would bend bars like rack
pulls are very very rough on bars that
that's not in I'm very strong statement
that is a if you do rack pulls with a
fair bit of weight that's very rough on
bars statement
um but yeah like I I like partials I
think they're fun
um
but I think that they have fallen out of
favor in a lot of circles these days
um I think that people became you know
generally acquainted with the principle
of specificity the idea that hey if I
want to get strong through a full range
of motion I should train through a full
range of motion and especially like
overload type partials so things like uh
board press or pin press or block poles
or half squats uh they've been I think
in the general consciousness of the
lifting Community kind of consigned to
to the bin of ego lifting
um you know where where maybe if you're
doing equipped to lifting where lockout
strength might be a really big concern
ah maybe they have a role but if
especially if you're trying to do raw
lifting
um I I just don't see as much partial
range of motion training as I used to
like it really seems to have fallen out
of favor but but partial range of motion
training uh through again through short
muscle links so like overload partials
do have a a long and illustrious history
in in the strength community so two of
the two of the great pioneers at least
of like the American strength training
tradition uh built some pretty legendary
lifts uh on the backs of a lot of
partials so uh one was Bob peoples who I
believe is the first person to ever
deadlift over 700 pounds
um his best deadlift was 728 at 181
which uh it which he pulled in 1946 I
believe which if he did it today would
still be the 12th best deadlift all time
in the 181 class uh for for like drug
tested federations and which I mean like
I don't think steroids had reached the
Backwoods of Tennessee which is where
Bob peoples was from in 1946 but even if
you're like ah like he he somehow had
the gear hook up a year after World War
II
um like that poll would still be top 50
at 181 even counting untested Fed so
like uh just just Leaps and Bounds ahead
of the competition back in the 40s
um he did a lot of you know what we
would know today as rackpoles to build
his deadlift a lot of deadlifts from
just baloney height just above uh knee
height in order to build his lockout
strength and then uh another very famous
example is Paul Anderson who built his
his legendary and I used that that term
with all of all of the assumed
connotations legendary both in terms of
it was doubtlessly a very impressive
squat but legendary also in the term of
it may have been a Legend and his squat
wasn't as good as people have claimed
um but yeah like an incredible squatter
um who it is claimed that he potentially
squatted 1200 pounds which uh I don't
know how much I buy that but also when
you see pictures of the guy
he looks like the type of guy who might
have been able to squat 1200 pounds hard
to say but um he was famous for like one
of his squat training methods is he
would dig a hole and basically just have
like a squat bar on the ground and get
down into the hole and just do partial
reps and then once he could do I think
like eight to ten reps at a at a certain
height he would just put some dirt in
the hole so now the hole is not quite as
deep and the range of motion is a little
bit longer and you know do partial
squats that way as well
um so if you've ever heard of people
referring to bottom-up pin squats as
Anderson squats that's why
um but just very cool very Innovative uh
you know you don't have a squat rack you
can just dig a hole very cool stuff also
just as an aside Paul Anderson did all
sorts of just like very fun sounding
training back in the day uh one story
and this is a little bit far afield but
it's it's a nice story that I think
people people should know so he was he
was most famous I think for just really
really incredible squat strength and
really really incredible overhead press
strength and one of the things he used
to do is he he had a farm he had a lot
of land and he just enjoyed golf like
like as as an amateur golfer I like I
don't think he was particularly good but
I I imagine it was it was a situation
where he could he could slap a drive a
mile
um and he would set up a squat rack on
either end of his big field and load
like 800 pounds on one of the bars and
like 400 pounds on the other bar and
just go out there with his driver a golf
ball and like a gallon of milk and start
on on the squat rack with 800 pounds do
a couple reps of squats smack the ball
across the field sipping on his milk as
he went and this was in Tennessee
um no no uh Bob peoples was from
Tennessee Paul Anderson was from some
somewhere in the South I think Georgia
but don't don't quote me on that okay
because when you said milk my first stop
was the old Anchorman milk was a bad
choice I just I just think of being like
98 Degrees squatting 800 gallon of milk
I mean are you good I guess he was just
built different yeah uh anyway smack the
ball to the other end of the field do
like two or three reps of shoulder press
with the 400 pound bar and then just
smack the ball back uh so you know
getting some steps in getting some low
intensity cardio and and just making a
day of of doing squats and overhead
press uh very very cool anyway so yeah
there's a there's a proud history of
partials in the strength training uh
tradition and one thing I'll note is the
um the story of Paul Anderson allegedly
squatting 1200 pounds is
far more interesting than I realized I
found a really cool article on breaking
muscle that will be linked in the show
notes
um essentially just breaking down how
plausible it was for it to have
potentially happened like essentially
the apparatus used for his alleged 1200
pound squat could it have actually held
1200 pounds
um like like what were the incentives
around this because essentially it was
it was a show
um where he was performing in a Casino
in Reno Nevada and instead of just like
a squat bar it was two big uh metal and
glass boxes that were allegedly loaded
with
um like 15 000 silver dollars so 7500 in
one box 7500 in the other box and that
in combination with the weight of the
apparatus itself was allegedly depending
who you ask either eleven hundred and
sixty pounds or 1200 pounds and he would
apparently uh go and squat it for a
crowd with kind of the the old the old
time circus strongman Gambit of if
anyone else in the audience can do this
uh you can have the the 1500 bucks which
this was I think in the 50s so that was
a ton of money back then and so you know
the article gets into well you know it
probably wasn't actually 1200 pounds but
there were other strong people back then
um and so there there was incentive for
it to be very very heavy because if it
wasn't and someone else claimed that
money you know the casino's out of
fifteen fifteen thousand dollars
um and also like the fact that it was
silver dollars is important because this
intersected with debates in the us at
the time about should we move to the
silver standard versus the gold standard
or like paper money all of that like
Williams Janine Bryan stuff
um and and the the folks who ran this
casino in Nevada were very into the idea
of a silver standard which you just
don't see that many overlaps between
power lifting and monetary policy so a
very cool story anyway intro out of the
way let's uh let's actually get into the
research on the topic
so
um
in general I think we all kind of know
and acknowledge this for the most part
if you had to pick one training modality
like if you had to pick one type of
range of motion to train through and you
wanted to build strength through a full
range of motion you should do full range
of motion training that is not
particularly controversial that's uh
strongly empirically supported
um uh in Milo's meta-analysis that was
one of the things they looked at and
like yeah for tests of full range of
motion strength full range of motion
training works better than partial range
of motion training like that's uh that's
not uh controversial at all however most
people who would be doing some partial
range of motion training are also still
going to be doing full range of motion
training as well like if you're a power
lifter and you want to do some block
pulls you'll probably still be doing
deadlifts from the floor if you want to
do some board press you'll probably
still be doing plenty of bench press to
your chest so I think the more
interesting and relevant question is
what does the research have to say about
combining different ranges of motion
instead of just doing full range of
motion training versus just doing
partial range motion training because
you know in in science we like to be
able to create clear dichotomies isolate
variables and just say Okay full range
versus partial range what are the
differences but at least for uh for
ecological validity to better reflect
how people train in the real world I I
think the the research looking at a
combination of different ranges of
motion is just a lot more informative
about
um what you could expect using the
methods that people would actually use
in real training so uh yeah let's let's
dive in there are four relevant studies
that I'm going to discuss here briefly
the first one was by Basler and
colleagues from 2014. uh all of the
studies I I mentioned will be in the
show notes and so in this study one
group so there were two groups of
subjects one group
um
just trained squats through a full range
of motion doing six sets twice per week
and the other group uh also trained
squats twice per week doing three sets
through a full range of motion and three
sets of partial squats so through about
80 degrees of knee flexion or or roughly
half squats so the total number of sets
were equated but one group just did all
full squats the other group did 50 50
full squats and half squats uh it was a
seven week training intervention and uh
long story short there weren't
statistically significant differences
between groups but the nominal
differences did Lean in favor of the
group doing a combination of full and
partial range of motion training so
their one rep max full squat increased
by about 8.2 percent on average versus
5.1 percent in the group only doing full
squats and also the the group doing a
combination of full and partial squats
experience nominally larger gains in
partial squat when rep max as well
though that is not particularly
surprising moving on the second study
was by Gillingham and debaliso and I'll
note the Gillingham in this study is
Brad Gillingham which if you're into
power lifting at all uh I assume you
know who Brad Gillingham is and if you
don't shame on you he is an absolute
Legend uh he won six World Championships
in power lifting and uh I I believe he
has still to this day pulled more than
800 pounds in competition more discreet
times than any other human just a
legendary deadlifter uh and his his best
deadlift was uh 400 kilos in in the
super heavyweight class so
it's it's very cool to see him uh
getting into the lab getting his hands
dirty and I'll note if if uh you're
listening to this and and you ever
encounter the perspective of someone
online being like ah man uh exercise
science researchers they don't know
anything about real strength training
anecdote that at least one of them does
uh Brad Gillingham absolute Legend in
powerlifting so in this group it was or
in this study it was a six-week training
study
um in a group of Collegiate wrestlers uh
undergoing their pre-season training
program and uh one group just did full
range of motion deadlifts
um the other group subbed out one of
those sets of full range of motion
deadlifts for uh three singles through a
partial range of motion from just above
uh the kneecap so the the total number
of sets weren't equated between groups
but the the group doing full only full
range of motion training it was like it
it was sets that looked like pretty
challenging sets of five and the the
singles for the the block polls that
they did or rack pulls weren't with like
super super super max loads not like 150
percent of one RM as someone who's done
a lot of deadlift training the the total
stress that the two groups underwent I
think was more or less equivalent just
just that is my my personal belief
um but yeah so they they trained for six
weeks uh the group only doing full range
of motion training uh actually
experienced a small non-significant
decrease in strength uh of about uh 5.3
kilos on their full full range of motion
deadlift whereas the group doing a
combination of full and partial range of
motion training uh experienced a small
increase in deadlift strength of about
4.5 kilos so again much like the Basler
study that didn't amount to a
statistically significant difference
between groups but the nominal
difference did did Lean in favor of
doing a combination of full and partial
range of motion training instead of just
full range of motion and then once again
very unsurprisingly uh the group doing
some partial range of motion training
also experienced a significantly larger
gains in uh rack pull strength so they
they tested one one rep max for rack
pulls as well uh moving on third study
was by Pedrosa and colleagues this one I
believe was published in 2021 and it's
not exactly uh the same as the prior
study so the prior two studies compared
full range of motion training versus a
combination of full and partial range
motion training this one compared full
range of motion training to a
combination of two different partial
ranges of motion so one group did knee
extensions through a full range of
motion the other group did half of their
sets through a partial range of motion
through the bottom half of the lift and
half of their sets through a partial
range of motion through the top half of
the lift so a combination of two
different partial ranges of motion
um and uh yeah overall this one was very
similar they they trained for 12 weeks
uh there were overall uh five groups in
this study so if you're watching on
YouTube when we uh throw up the figure
from the study you will see uh five bars
but the the two that are relevant for
this discussion here will have a red box
around them
um but yeah uh so they they tested uh
strength gains in this study through uh
the bottom half of the range of motion
so so partial range of motion strength
through the bottom half partial range of
motion strength through the top half and
also uh full range of motion strength
gains through the full range of motion
uh and in all cases the combination of
those two partial ranges of motion
produce larger strength gains than just
training through a full range of motion
again even when equating uh total sets
and the difference was statistically
significant for strength gains through
the bottom half of the range of motion
but for full range of motion strength
gains as we saw in the Basler study and
the Gillingham study nominal differences
in favor of the partials but it wasn't a
statistically significant difference
then finally the last of these four
studies 2020 paper by Whaley and
colleagues
um and and this one was slightly
different again instead of so the other
the other three studies essentially
you'd have one group doing full range of
motion training and the other groups
basically doing half of their training
through a full range of motion or
through the bottom half of the range of
motion and half of their training
through a partial range of motion and
short muscle lengths and you know like
50 50 per session per week whatever in
the Whaley study they used Progressive
range of motion training much like uh
Paul Anderson filling in that hole for
his Progressive range of motion squats
this was a seven week training study
there was one group squatting through a
full range of motion every session and
another group doing Progressive range of
motion training so they were doing pin
squats basically starting from like a
quarter squat height with the pins
getting lower and lower and lower each
workout such that by week seven it was
basically doing pin squats through
effectively a full range of motion
um and once again just like the other
three studies they tested full range of
motion squat one rep max and there
wasn't a statistically significant
difference between groups but the
nominal differences once again leaned in
favor of the group doing a combination
of full and partial range of motion
training in this case it was Progressive
range of motion training so that group
experienced a 14 and a half kilo
increase in squat one rep max on average
versus 11 kilos for the group only doing
full range motion training and also in
this study they looked at gains in
vertical jump height which were also
nominally larger in the group doing
Progressive range of motion training so
when you look at these four studies in
aggregate
um you know it's it's a bit of a
Rorschach test I would say
um if you wanted to interpret them very
very conservatively you could say hey
scientists have had four bites at the
Apple this time and have thus far failed
to pre fail to demonstrate statistically
significant differences between these
two training Styles or you could
interpret it a little more liberally and
say well look you know the the concept
of statistical significance is kind of
arbitrary in the first place
um you know is is p of 0.07 really that
different from P of 0.03 uh and
ultimately we have four relatively
similar studies finding very similar
results
um so you know maybe there's something
to it and ultimately I'm
still skeptical but bullish I would say
like I would want to see another couple
of studies uh like I I think if we got
two more studies that also showed kind
of nominal differences in favor of the
combination even if they weren't
statistically significant or just one
more study where there was like a pretty
big statistically significant very
notable difference between the two
approaches I'd be like yeah yeah like at
this point we can probably cash this in
put put a pretty pretty substantial
number of eggs in that basket but yeah
it's it's to me right now kind of right
on that knife's edge of of how seriously
we should take this
um but it I mean the the balance of
evidence to this point does broadly
suggest that a combination of full and
partial range of motion training
probably on average produces slightly
larger strength gains than exclusively
training through a full range of motion
then the next the next obvious question
is well why would that be and
to be honest I'm not sure
um it could simply be a matter of
variety so there was a 2014 paper by
Fonseca and colleagues to kind of use as
an object lesson here where there were
two groups in that study that only did
squats and two groups in that study that
did squats and also a variety of other
lower body exercises but you know uh
like for example the two groups just
doing squats I think wound up doing like
eight sets of squats per workout and the
group's doing a variety of exercises
would do two sets of squats two sets I
think of deadlifts two sets of lunges or
something like that maybe two sets of uh
uh essentially like [ __ ] squat
something like that I I forget all of
the details but that that was the basic
setup and uh the groups doing a variety
of different exercises in that study uh
gained more squat strength in the groups
just doing squats uh which suggests that
you know like you you certainly need
specificity to gain strength but there
there might just be some inherent
benefit to having some variety and not
being hyper specific all the time so you
know in this case that could be all
we're seeing you know maybe maybe
partial range of motion training isn't
like super beneficial per se but just
like subbing out a third or a half of
your full range of motion training like
if you're doing 20 sets of
full range of motion squats you know
maybe like competition style maybe
subbing out 10 of those sets for half
squats or pin squats or pause squats or
box squats or band squats or just like
basically anything else like it could we
could just be seen in effect that is
attributable to variety rather than
partial range of motion training per se
um it's it I think this is uh somewhat
dubious but I I think I would get called
out for it if I didn't at least mention
it one uh one kind of like historical
reason that that people have cited in
the past for why like overload style
partial short muscle length partials
that that you can just load heavier than
full range of motion training one reason
people have proposed that those might be
beneficial is that they could have uh
like outsized effects on connective
tissue strength or bone strength which
you know Downstream of that that might
result in larger strength gains to my
knowledge there's not much if any direct
evidence for this
um and the research we do have looking
at uh like changes in in tendon strength
with training tends to suggest that load
actually isn't all that important like
resistance training is good but as long
as it's like a reasonably challenging
load it seems to have like pretty
comparable effects on gains and tendon
strength so I'm pretty skeptical about
that but you know that is a potential
mechanism that hasn't been directly
investigated so can't fully rule it out
and then another possibility is that it
could be mostly psychological where uh
especially for one rep max testing and
especially for people who aren't that
experienced with one rep max testing
there there's kind of the the oh [ __ ]
factor you know like if if you're
attempting a new one rep max bench
attempting a new one rep max squat uh as
soon as you unrack that weight and feel
it in your hands or on your shoulders
maybe you're capable of it but Jesus
Christ it's just [ __ ] scary you know
uh if you've never touched anything that
heavy before so you know it could be
that uh overload partials just help on
that front just get you used to feeling
more weight so that maybe they don't
actually make you that much stronger but
they kind of help you psychologically be
able to lift the weights you are
actually capable of lifting without just
kind of shutting down and locking up
when you feel those really heavy one rep
max attempts it'd be really cool if
someone were to do a study uh where they
did like for example if they were
looking at squats and had the you know
had one of the groups just doing
walkouts to try to kind of be like hey
just so you know here's what this really
heavy stuff feels like yeah like there
would be a way experimentally to get at
that but I mean I assume no one's done
that I I don't believe they have yeah
um but I I will note I don't think that
this potential explanation explains all
of these findings because the the
Pedrosa study was looking at knee
extensions and I don't think anyone gets
like that oh [ __ ] feeling you get for a
one rep max squat when you feel a really
heavy load against your ankle for knee
extensions you know like I just I don't
think that's a thing you're not lifting
the way I'm lifting fair enough
um
but yeah so you know this is I I think a
an interesting and developing uh area of
research that that like I said I'm not
willing to put uh the the full like
unabashed stamp of approval on it I'm
not willing to put all of my eggs in the
basket of saying it is definitely
beneficial to do a combination of full
and partial range of motion training
versus just full range of motion
training like we're we're definitely not
to that point yet uh but I do find this
this interesting and pretty promising
um one other thing to note about these
studies is I'm mostly focused on the
gains in full range of motion one rep
max strength uh like those outcomes
because I mean quite simply I know that
that's what most of the people in our
audience care about
um but these studies did report a
variety of other benefits that also
leaned in favor of doing a combination
of full and partial range of motion
training so like I mentioned with the
Pedrosa study they tested strength not
just through a full range of motion but
through the bottom of the range of
motion and the top of the range of
motion and the
variety partial range of motion group
like doing half through the bottom half
through the top that seemed to
outperform full range of motion training
through all three of those ranges of
motion in the Basler study
um there there were some measurements
looking at rate of force development
during isometric squats that stuff
leaned in favor of a combination of full
and partial range of motion training in
the Gillingham study again
non-significant difference for gains in
full range of motion deadlift strength
but a significant difference in favor of
a combination of full and partial in
terms of gain in in terms of gains in
partial range of motion deadlift
strength and then for the Whaley study
they looked at Jump height as well again
nominal difference leaning in favor of
progressive range of motion training in
in that group or in that study so you
know it seems like there's
um
it seems like there there might be just
like other small upsides of of doing a
bit of partial range of motion training
as well beyond potential beneficial
effects on full range of motion one rep
max strength gains
um so yeah like it's it's it's
interesting but uh
I'm not like 100 sold on it yet that's
that's about where I'm at so in terms of
the verdict here and and my
recommendations after uh you know going
through this body of research and
ruminating and ruminating on it a little
bit
um I think that there's definitely a
situation where it does make a lot of
sense to do some partial range of motion
training uh for the purpose of strength
development and that is you know if
you're if your weakness is through the
top part of a range of motion for a
particular lift like if you miss
deadlifts at lockout if you miss bench
press at lockout probably not going to
miss squats at lockout like it's it's
mostly it's mostly uh bench press and
deadlift but you know in in that case uh
board press pin press block pulls rack
pulls might make a ton of sense to add
in independent of just like the general
the generalized effects of combining
ranges of motion in your case like it
seems like the partial range of motion
training can help correct a specific
issue you have and help you develop
strength through a range of motion where
you're currently weak so for for if
you're in that boat seems like some
partial range of motion training makes
all the sense in the world if you're not
in that boat
um I'm not I'm not ready to confidently
say that subbing out some of your full
range of motion training for partials
will definitely improve strength gains
uh but but I am bullish overall
um and also like my my personal
experience with this is overall positive
um like I I don't know that I've gotten
that much out of partials for bench
press but I have gotten a lot out of
partials for deadlift in particular
um my deadlift was uh stalled in the
like low 600s for a long time and doing
Progressive range of motion deadlift
training just like starting at like 800
pounds for very very partial range of
motion deadlifts like from well above uh
knee height and you know just just going
down
um like like going down in in rack
height after I could get five or ten
reps so you know two inch range of
motion to start with once I get get 10
reps there uh drop it down a couple
inches once I could get 10 reps there
drop it down a couple inches
um and once I could pull 800 for like
like four or five reps from just below
knee height I could put the bar on the
floor and deadlift over seven like it it
seemed to put about 80 pounds on my
deadlift uh doing that
um and I'll note it only seemed to work
once I've tried that again I didn't see
the same effect but at least through one
one run of partial range of motion or
like Progressive range of motion
deadlift training I got a ton of mileage
out of it so
um you know my my personal experience
with with partials at least like
partially backs up the research here
um
and just as a couple final notes uh uh
doing partial range of motion training
at Short muscle length so kind of
overload partials is probably worse for
hypertrophy than full range of motion
training so you know if you're
um if you're attempting to move up a
weight class by adding more muscle to
your frame or you know just trying to to
build more muscle fill out your frame so
you can lift more
um You probably don't want to go
overboard with with the overload
partials
um and if you do SUB out like a pretty
significant percentage of your full
range of motion training four partials
may not be a bad idea to do some
targeted accessories to kind of fill
that Gap so you know if you uh were
previously doing 20 sets of bench press
per week and you move to doing 10 sets
of full range of motion bench press and
like 10 sets of
um you know rack presses or board
presses or something like that may not
be a terrible idea to add in some
additional accessory exercises for your
pecs and triceps to kind of make up for
that difference
there's no research on that but I think
just kind of a priori that's that's
probably not a bad idea to make sure
you're not compromising hypertrophy
results and then uh finally just just a
parting note
um I I think that there's this this uh
since at least in some communities that
doing any sort of overload partial is
just purely ego lifting
um that there's no possible beneficial
effect you could get from it
um so if you know if you want to give
partials a shot maybe you do some half
squats maybe you do some block pulls
whatever if someone tries to call you
out for ego lifting uh yeah [ __ ] them
you know that's that's kind of my
perspective and uh send them to to this
episode of The Stronger by science
podcast to and tell them to use a
discount code too yeah absolutely yeah
um but yeah like they're it's to to be
extremely clear like there is some
promising research in this area it is
absolutely and very much not uh purely
ego lifting all right good stuff
you ready to move on yes sir all right
so I've got a segment that is actually
pretty short here so a lot of times I
will make a tidy list of the 27 points
that I'm trying to make over the course
of a segment in this case it's really
just one pretty broad point and we want
to look at it from a few different
angles
um so before I get into it Greg a
question for you uh
Fitness oriented diet you know we're
going to really clean up the diet uh
pursuing some kind of body composition
goal like let's say maybe you know going
to you know build some muscle lose some
body fat maybe you're trying to recomp
what are the two most important values
that you're going to track and monitor
as it pertains to your diet uh probably
total calorie intake and protein intake
that is a very sensible answer so
obviously total calorie intake is going
to have a huge impact I mean it's it's
going to you know determine whether or
not you're in negative or positive
energy balance or neutral and it's
really going to have a huge impact on
how your body weight and body fat
fluctuate over the course of the diet uh
but protein is a close second because
without question we know that you need
enough protein to support your goals
whether you're trying to build new
muscle or maintain the muscle that you
have during a fat loss phase it's a very
uncontroversial to suggest that if you
intentionally restrict your protein to
very low levels that's not going to be
great for hypertrophy right so a lot of
times you know we'll interact with folks
who say you know I'd like to clean up my
diet a little bit but
I'm not really that interested in really
meticulously watching my carb intake and
my my fat intake and the ratio between
them in many cases we can just say
whatever it's fine just watch your
calories watch your protein the exact
amount of carbs and fats in most cases
not really going to matter that much uh
so we know that calories are absolutely
crucial but we know that protein is
important too
um and in the evidence-based Fitness
World
almost everybody recommends getting
around 1.6 to 2.2 grams per kilogram per
day of protein a lot of people
alternatively will say well go for like
one gram of protein per pound of body
weight which is 2.2 grams per kilogram
so there's this particular range that
has gotten really really really popular
and what I want to the question I want
to address in this segment here is
how important is it to specifically get
within that precise range because I
suspect while I agree that that is a
very good range and and kind of the if
you know nothing about someone you just
know that muscle is important to them
and they're into fitness how much
protein should they get that is the
range of numbers that I would start with
in a in a majority of cases but I
suspect that a lot of people really
dramatically overestimate the downsides
and the ramifications of undershooting
this target range just a little bit uh
you know we came out with macro Factor
over a year ago this is a really common
genre of question is am I eating enough
protein if I go from the moderate
setting to the low setting is am I
losing something in that process protein
intake comes up a lot and it's usually
coming from a place of concern about
what if I don't get 1.6 grams per
kilogram per day so there was a
relatively new meta-analysis I think it
I think it was published like an e-print
online ahead of print a couple months
ago or a few months ago but it was by
Nunes and colleagues and it the the
title was systematic review and
meta-analysis of protein intake to
support muscle mass and function in
healthy adults so in terms of the
purpose a little quote here we the
authors performed a systematic review
meta-analysis and meta regression to
determine if increasing daily protein
ingestion contributes to gaining lean
body mass muscle strength and physical
slash functional test performance in
healthy subjects so they did a really
nice uh meta analytic model they did a
three level random effects model which
uh properly accounts for everything that
they should have been accounting for
statistically they did a very nice job
with their analysis and they were able
to pool data from a total of 74
randomized control trials that fit their
inclusion criteria
now I'm going to cut right to the chase
here there's a quote with the the
results here the evidence suggests that
increasing daily protein ingestion May
enhance gains in lean body mass in
studies enrolling subjects in resistance
exercise
the standardized mean difference the
effect size basically was 0.22
and uh so yeah they concluded yes adding
more protein generally a positive thing
for lean body mass I'm not going to get
into all the strength and physical
function stuff because if your protein
is making you stronger it's probably
happening via increases in muscle mass
in in this kind of framework in this
kind of research approach
um now that that sounds like okay yeah
that makes sense and then when you look
into the uh the table here if you look
at table two in the original paper and
I'll put it up on the screen here you
can see that there is to some extent a
bit of a graded effect
um so they they looked at the trials
with lifters where protein was under 1.2
grams per kilogram per day and the
effect size was negative 0.14 which so
basically indicating it wasn't
statistically significant you'd look at
that and say well why would more protein
lead or you know why would there be a
negative effect size of lifting with you
know protein under 1.2 you'd still
expect some relatively positive effect
but you know basically when you look at
the confidence interval we can interpret
that as basically zero-ish you know so
it's not like you know lifting on a low
protein diet is going to induce
precipitous muscle loss or anything like
that but but the effect size in terms of
lean body mass gains uh four people who
were consuming less than 1.2 grams per
kilogram per day of protein was negative
0.14 when they then looked at
participants who were ingesting between
1.2 and 1.59 which is conveniently right
below that kind of optimal range we
talked about the effect size was 0 0.17
so it was in in the positive direction
there uh just on the borderline of what
we might call a trivial effect size and
then when they bumped it up to looking
at studies where intake was at least 1.6
grams per kilogram per day then the
effect size bumped up to 0.3 so this is
assuming you know we're kind of putting
these studies into bins and of course
all these studies are going to vary
across a a variety of different domains
and characteristics but broadly speaking
you could look at it and say okay that
tells us that we definitely want to have
plenty of protein and when we bump up
into the higher categories we see better
outcomes for lean body mass but there
was a quote in the uh I think in the
discussion section that I think really
highlights the point that I'm getting at
here so
they said uh they're looking at that
standardized mean difference basically
higher protein versus lower Point lower
protein the effect size was 0.22 and
they said the change represents
approximately 1.3 to 1.4 Kilograms of
lean mass gain during the intervention
compared to an average of about 0.8
kilogram gain in the placebo or control
group so what they were looking at here
just broadly speaking comparing higher
versus lower protein intakes was a
difference of about 0.5 to 0.7 kilograms
in terms of lean body mass accretion uh
so so they were kind of saying like
listen yeah this analysis indicates that
higher protein is broadly better for for
uh the accretion of lean body mass but
we're not talking about an enormous
effect here we're not talking about
several additional kilograms of lean
body mass Within These studies we're
talking about more like a half a
kilogram and then when you look look at
there's a big uh figure that I'm going
to put on the screen here when you start
to look at
the the actual effect sizes in this
Forest plot
you kind of get a better sense of the
data where for for a lot of these
studies the effect size is very
comfortably straddling the line of zero
you know when you look at the at the
confidence intervals a lot of these uh
individual effect sizes are
zero-ish or very near zero so I think
it's important to look at these effect
sizes effect sizes and really kind of
chew on them and look at them and
interpret them visually so that you can
see like when we talk about how critical
high protein is what are we really
talking about here in more tangible
terms like not just is there an effect
but what is the size of the effect and
how consistent is that effect uh and so
I think that figure uh shows it pretty
nicely if we go on there's a I dug into
the supplementary file and found figure
12 here which is on the screen now it's
a bubble plot and it's basically just
showing uh on the x-axis uh you know
what is the protein ingestion in grams
per kilogram per day and then the y-axis
is just indicating the amount of
increase in lean body mass that was
observed and you look at it and you can
definitely say okay that looks like a
line that's pointing upward right but
you also see see like you know if I'm
looking at people who are at three grams
per kilogram per day
I'm looking at a spread that on the
y-axis ranges from a value of one to you
know maybe like negative 0.25 something
like that yeah and if I look all the way
down at like
1.2 grams per kilogram of protein I'm
seeing a spread from like negative 0.5
up to like 1.7 now there is one that is
a bit of an outlier in that regard
that's the the 1.7 value is really
separated from the pack and I will
acknowledge this is very much a visual
uh segment that I'm doing here so uh if
you're listening Along on a purely audio
platform might not be a bad idea to
check out the YouTube for a little more
context but I am going to try to you
know verbally describe what we're seeing
here but if you exclude a couple very
very high values
um that are kind of just I I don't I
don't use the term outlier because
there's some statistical connotations
that I haven't rigorously checked here
but but there are a couple values that
are really far away from the pack and if
you exclude those this looks like a
relatively
flat relationship once we're getting
above like 1.3 ish something like that
uh so with that in mind I wanted to take
I want to take it back to the original
uh so everyone always talks about this
um this range of 1.6 to 2.2 grams per
kilogram per day
and that range specifically to the best
of my knowledge comes from a 2018
meta-analysis by Morton and colleagues
um so they publish this work it's an
excellent meta-analysis and meta
regression project by Morton and
colleagues so I don't want it to seem as
if I'm being critical of this work I'm
rather highlighting this work and saying
let's dig in and kind of get some Nuance
from it here so uh Greg uh what we're
looking at here
um
is a figure from that study uh and it is
the figure that you see on just about
every uh evidence-based article about
protein intake uh and if you're watching
Along on YouTube you can see the figure
on the screen what I did here was I I
used web plot did web plot digitizer
which is a great tool for for kind of
extracting values from figures and
studies and I plotted it myself because
I wanted to get rid of the lines this is
a conversation you and I have had many a
time over the years when you throw a
best fit line on a regression model it
poisons your mind like you get so
fixated on the regression line like I
could take uh just a random plot of
totally just a plot with no relationship
at all if I just throw a regression line
in there you're gonna be like oh yeah I
see that Trend that makes sense yeah
um so I took all the the lines out and
stuff like that not that they're
misleading they're they're a good choice
for the original paper but
if we just look at this distribution
broadly
how would you describe it Greg
oh man
um
yeah I mean it just just eyeballing it
it looks like there is maybe a very
slight positive Association here but
um
I don't know it doesn't look like
there's any like super super clear
discernible pattern like there are
definitely fewer low values in the
vicinity of 1.0 than there are in the
vicinity of 1.75 for example but
um yeah I mean it it doesn't look like
it's not a super super clean uh super
super strong relationship uh but I would
say yeah and I mean
not to cherry pick but I'll go ahead and
cherry pick uh but you know you look at
this
um
at this distribution and you say well if
I was consuming
uh
1.3 grams per kilogram per day how
certain am I that my gains will be
materially different from someone who's
consuming 2.1
and with it if you start bidding it up
into little little uh little sections
like that you start to say man it's it's
actually kind of hard to to look at a
particular intake and say oh I'm quite
confident that you're going to be far
worse off uh at 1.5 compared to 2.25
um but anyway I'm going to show on the
screen here uh it's contextualized a
little bit more by adding some access
labels just so that we can kind of get
our bearings uh and kind of really fully
contextualize what we're what we're
looking at not just with values but but
with uh with access labels uh and then
of course I'm going to show on the
screen a linear trend line so this
linear trend line does indicate that
there is broadly speaking a positive
trajectory to this data uh the trend the
r squared value for the linear trend
line is 0.126 so what that tells us is
protein intake in grams per kilogram per
day is explaining about 12 or 13 percent
of the variance in uh gains in fat-free
Mass uh now one thing I should
acknowledge is that the authors used a
breakpoint analysis in the original
paper which means they would suggest
that a linear trend is not the
appropriate trend line for this
um but if we we look at a recreation of
the original figure
um this was actually taken from a
stronger by science article uh but but
when you add in the uh the non-linear
trend line with a break point in it you
start to see where that 1.6 number comes
from right so the the uh in the original
paper they did this breakpoint analysis
and they said statistically speaking our
best estimate of the break point here
is 1.6 and the reason they're looking
for a break point is they're saying how
high do I have to get my protein to to
get to a spot where I can say this is
Comfortably enough to effectively
maximize my gains here yeah what they're
looking at is where does this
relationship between protein and gains
and fat free Mass essentially become
flat so that's what you're seeing on the
screen but the confidence interval for
that break point essentially spans the
entirety of the data uh so so the
statistical interpretation of this would
be the break point is at 1.6 but the 95
percent confidence interval ranges from
I forget the exact numbers but it was
basically like from one to like 2.2 ish
or something like that yeah yeah
um
now this was a really fantastic piece of
research and I like I said I don't want
to make it seem like I'm being critical
but what I want to encourage people to
do is look at these data slightly
differently okay because everyone sees
this figure and when you draw the the
trend line with the break point you say
oh yeah yeah that makes sense give me
1.6 at least
um but what I want to do is kind of
reframe what we're looking at here so um
in the previous uh systematic review I
was talking about the meta-analysis by
Nunes the newer one uh I mentioned that
they had kind of broken it into
categories and one of their categories
was they're like well let's look at
intakes above 1.2 that was kind of a a
threshold that they identified now if we
look at the same data and Greg you can
follow along here we're looking at this
data and we're cutting off everything
below 1.2
that starts to really change the nature
of this relationship to my eye yeah I I
don't know if you would agree with that
I think it still looks like there's a
positive relationship there but it does
not look to be quite as as a substantial
upward Trend I would definitely agree
with that and now on the screen we're
going to look at adding in a trend line
and we're just going with a linear trend
line here uh and I would actually I
would contend that the linear trend line
is a fairly appropriate fit for this
data uh from my perspective no yeah I I
agree so when we look at that linear
trend line and we cut out the the
intakes below 1.2 and that's that's not
like arbitrary again I'm trying to kind
of pull that number from the Nunes
review we see that the r squared value
becomes
0.044 and so what that's telling us is
once we're looking at intakes above 1.2
grams per kilogram per day
protein intake is only explaining about
four percent maybe five percent of the
variance in changes in fat-free mass in
these studies uh and there is one value
in this uh in this particular data set
that is kind of it's certainly not an
outlier but it is Head and Shoulders
Above the Rest you know there's this one
value up there that's hanging out well
above three on the y-axis that does seem
to kind of
nudge us towards saying oh yeah it looks
like there's really something to these
extra high protein intakes so what I did
here is uh I essentially just removed
that one value
um which I now we're getting into the
realm of cherry picking a bit well
haters might call it cherry picking but
someone else might call it a uh a leave
one out analysis exactly and that is a
good point is that it's a very selective
leave one out analysis but a lot of
times when when someone is saying okay
you're doing a meta-analysis a meta
regression are you sure that one fluky
study isn't really driving the effect
here and what you'll do is to leave one
out analysis where you'll go through and
recalculate the whole analysis just
taking out one study at a time so you
take one study out you leave the rest
recalculate the whole meta and say okay
let's try it by pulling out a different
study so the original one goes back in
you take a new one out and you
recalculate again if that sounds awful
and tedious and unbearable
by the grace of God we have software and
so that whole process is one line of
code yeah so Props to people who make
software but but yeah and so to be clear
ultimately what you're trying to do with
a with a leave one out analysis is you
want to make sure that one particularly
influential data point isn't just
driving your results or having an undue
amount of weight so uh you know if
you're calculating an effect size or a
beta coefficient you know do you do you
see like a 20 shift in your beta
coefficient and your your p-value go
from like 0.04 to 0.15 if you leave one
study I like do you see and this is I
think oftentimes it's somewhat
subjective like basically you're just
looking to see are are there any studies
that are really really influencing this
this pooled effect we're we're observing
yeah it is subjective but you know
you're gonna if you're gonna leave one
out analysis and there's just one
particular study and all of a sudden
you're you're pooled effect size you
know drops by 30 you're like oh crap
like something is really happening here
you know and I'll note just as as a bit
of inside baseball
I've noticed that leave one out analyzes
aren't done super frequently in
meta-analyzes and it seems like they're
almost always done when the researchers
just like do their literature search
extract the data plot it and they're
like ah [ __ ] like we've I I know what
I'm seeing here I know one of these
studies is skewing my results so let's
say we plan to do it leave one out
analysis and then we can present the
results with and without that one study
yeah yeah it's uh it's a convenient way
to say like how can I say that that one
researcher is completely full of [ __ ]
but but make it a systematic process
yeah essentially or or at least get me
off the hook for pretending that that
one particular finding is actually like
representative and and should be
included yeah yeah uh but anyway so if
we if we remove that one it doesn't
really change that much honestly I I did
it because I expected that I would look
at the data and say whoa things are
fundamentally quite different here it
doesn't really change that much and you
know it's on the screen you can kind of
make your own assessment there it still
looks like there's generally speaking an
upward trajectory but in the interest of
being transparent if I thought it was
going to be Nifty I included it even
though it's it doesn't really
fundamentally change things that much
um I don't want to just like only
include things that are that I expect to
be interesting that end up looking
interesting yeah um so then when we look
at the trend line
again you know we do see that the r
squared value drops from 0.044 uh to
0.029 that's inconsequential uh
effectively no impact there
um and now I'm full-blown cherry picking
um but cherry picking to prove a point
so I mentioned to be fair I think that's
why most people cherry pick correct yeah
yeah so I'm yeah I'm I'm not hiding the
uh method by which I am selecting fruit
I am cherry picking here but it's merely
to be an illustration which is
but I do think it's pertinent here when
we're saying we're going to use this
body of literature to determine the
minimum uh protein intake that we should
be not just shooting for but stressing
over yeah yeah so like if you are going
to say here is the data set we're using
to make that determination I think you
should be able to stress test it and
provide various different cutoffs and
say well how how did the data look when
we frame it this way yeah I if I I think
that's an important consideration like
what what you're doing here I don't
think either of us would argue is like
the best and generalizably most rigorous
way to approach this but since there is
the question of of of magnitude and
impact like if if this is the type of
thing that is worth stressing about
that's really really worth getting in
your head about it should be I would
think robust to you know constraining
the x-axis to an arbitrary degree and
excluding one study you know yeah if
like those are those are definitely Two
Cherry picky type things to do but
ultimately that's not
that's not any sort of like extreme data
torturing and if if the relation the if
the previously observed relationship
falls apart with that level of stress
testing that doesn't mean that the
previously observed relationship doesn't
exist and isn't maybe worth paying
attention to but it probably does mean
that it's not a uh a generalizably
strong enough thing that you need to
lose sleep over it yeah and and to be to
be very clear I think the exclusion of
one data point is a much more uh
questionable practice than just saying
okay if you're telling me it I that
being below 1.6 is deleterious I should
be able to cut this x-axis at 1.3 and
still see it yeah right because the I'm
still including the cut Point here
correct so I think that the x-axis
modifications are fair game the
exclusion of one study questionable but
as I've shown I'm just reporting like
what I was poking around at and it
frankly didn't matter so excluding that
one study is the more questionable
practice and it's the least impactful
practice of what we're looking at here
yeah so cherry picking I'm just saying
hey let's cut the x-axis at 1.24 and
just see if we really still believe that
that 1.6 cut off is a very clear sharp
delineation between sub-optimal and
optimal protein intake and when we look
at the figure including that one study
that's a little larger than the others
it's just not looking like there's much
going on here at all
um it's it's really difficult to say
that people between 1.25 and 1.75 are
worse off than people at 2.0 and above
uh it it it looks like a lot of what's
going into that upward trajectory that
we see in the original data set is the
stuff occurring below
1.24 grams per kilogram per day if we
throw a linear trend line in there we
get an r squared value of 0.011 so we're
explaining one percent of the variance
in the change in fat-free Mass if we
remove that uh that one additional data
point that's a little bit larger than
the rest uh it doesn't really
fundamentally change the visual
inspection that much but when you know
when we throw on the uh the trend line
again it just doesn't change that much
we've dropped from 0.01 ish to 0.003
um now what is the point of this whole
practice it's to say we ought to uh
stress test that range a little bit and
ask ourselves not just what is the best
cut off we can choose because I you know
while it's not
um it's not a standard statistical
practice to say let's find the break
point forget the lower half of the
confidence interval and only look at the
upper half I I have not seen that as a
commonplace statistical method
um
but I I actually I I mean I think it's a
justifiable way to view it um in in
practical in a practical sense so I'm
not faulting the researchers for doing
that but it is worth kind of just
putting that out there
um but but if if the claim is
1.6 you got to get there and if not
you're going to regret it then we should
be able to cut the axis off at 1.24 and
say do we still feel that way uh and
when we look at this data I think it
largely conforms kind of to something
that we talked about a long time ago on
the show without any data in front of us
without any kind of evidence you know
without a direct piece of evidence we
were going by we were talking about like
what is the lowest protein intake that
you feel generally like fine about yeah
and we didn't say the RDA of 0.8 we were
both in agreement that that was pretty
low uh the number that we both felt
pretty good about was like Hey get above
like 1.2 ish
um looking at this data would not
strictly uh you know uh reinforce that
number it would say
1.25-ish might be where you want to get
above if we're going to you know assume
that this data is uh you know the best
possible data that we can pull together
to answer this and I I think that it is
a very nice representative data set for
that yeah so what I'm getting at here I
think it's important to clarify what I
am concluding but more importantly what
I'm not concluding so I am not saying
that protein is unimportant nothing in
this presentation would or in this
segment would indicate that I am not
saying that protein is unrelated to
gains in fat-free Mass it clearly is uh
I'm not saying that 1.6 to 2.2 grams per
kilogram is an ineffective optimal
protein Target I actually still very
much believe that that is a very nice if
you were to ask me with no additional
knowledge about the situation someone's
trying to build muscle how much protein
and if I if you tell me to scale it by
total body mass I'm going to say 1.6 to
2.2 uh
I'm not saying that that is a bad Target
but what I am concluding
is a few very important points first of
all resistance training drives muscle
growth but the protein we're adding in
there is merely permissive and we
shouldn't lose sight of that there's a
lot of folks who worry way too much
about their exact protein intake and not
enough about am I doing the things
required to stimulate muscle growth the
the training component is really driving
the ship here uh the protein is Simply
Having a permissive effect so all we're
trying to do is get the protein high
enough to really let those gains
materialize and manifest uh what I am
concluding is protein restriction to
very low levels is definitely bad for
your gains but clearly at really high
levels of protein it becomes a bit
redundant and even the original meta by
by Morton would reinforce that point
with the flat relationship above 1.6
um but the main point I want to make
here is that there is a massive uh
I would say overestimation of the cost
of setting your protein Target at 1.4
1.5 grams per kilogram per day when we
compare it to that optimal range of 1.6
to 2.2 there's a really pervasive
misconception that the low end of that
optimal range has been determined with a
high level of precision and that there
is a very clear uh downturn in your
progress if you fall just a little bit
short of that yeah when we look at this
data and say
what what if you get 1.3 1.4 1.5 the
data would indicate that the difference
between
getting pretty damn sufficient protein
intake in that 1.3 1.4 1.5 range the
difference between pretty damn
sufficient and fully optimal is very
very slim and the lines separating those
two categories is actually pretty hard
to draw when you just put the data out
there and say where are we seeing the
dramatic drop off in gains as protein
gets lower and lower and lower so what I
would encourage people to do is be just
a little bit less uh dogmatic about the
idea that every human being should have
that lifts should have their protein
between 1.6 and 2.2
um you know I if you were to go out into
like a message board or a forum if those
still exist I don't know you were to go
into a subreddit and say hey I just
hired a new fitness coach I'm trying to
put put on some muscle they gave me this
diet uh recommendation and the protein
targets 1.5 grams per kilogram per Dairy
for this example 1.4 you're going to get
about two-thirds of that group who says
you got to fire this person right away
yeah they're a [ __ ] fraud they're
fully incompetent and the other
one-third is going to say they should be
in jail yeah uh like the visceral
reactions well and and you might have uh
one angry very radicalized vegan who
says like no abs abs that's way too high
like your kidneys are [ __ ] yeah and
before we get angry messages I actually
am vegan now I haven't told you that yet
but uh congrats I I have made the the
transition The Only Exception is that I
am still I haven't been eating eggs much
because I don't feel like it yeah I'm
still very comfortable eating the eggs
from my local animal rescue because
those chickens live a better life than I
do and the reason I went vegan is just
for Animal Welfare concerns so like
those those chickens are doing just fine
um and to be clear that was that was a
comment about a a particular I think
relatively small subsection of vegans
not not vegans generally yeah but but
small subsections tend to be very
outspoken yes and that that's definitely
the case
um but anyway yeah like there has been
this um this widespread uh
adoption of that optimal range without a
lot of nuance behind it
um and it has led to a lot of mission
misinterpretations like the example I
just described which of course was
hyperbolic but I think isn't necessarily
unrepresentative
um and so with that in mind I do want to
talk uh I I want to remind people uh
that if if you're getting your protein
like 1.3 to 1.5 grams per kilogram per
day and bumping it up to 1.6 is
challenging it's infeasible it's
inconvenient or it's simply just
unpleasant for you it based on the
research does not make a lot of sense to
totally beat yourself up about that I
think people are are really disconnected
from the actual magnitude of what they
might be theoretically missing out on
there and I think there are a lot of uh
specific scenarios where I would look at
someone's diet look at their lifestyle
look at the sacrifices it would take to
get them from 1.3 to 1.6 or 1.8 I would
say honestly the the juice there is not
worth the squeeze
um it doesn't make a lot of sense for us
to be losing sleep over this and in fact
the Sleep we're losing over this is
probably more impactful than the protein
that we're missing yeah yeah
um so with that in mind I do want to
wrap this up with some kind of practical
ranges that people can lean on here and
I want to frame them based on total body
mass but also based on fat free Mass
because
um
one point of confusion that comes up a
lot from that kind of standard optimal
range is you'll find people who maybe
their goal is to lose 120 pounds right
and they're saying I read on the
internet I need to eat at least 1.6
grams per kilogram per day but my my
protein intake is astronomically High
yeah
um and the the fact of the matter is you
know when we scale by total body mass
alone there are certain ranges of the
body composition Spectrum where this
recommendation starts to really fall
flat
um and scaling to fat free mass is not a
perfect solution but it is an upgrade in
certain scenarios yeah so the category
that I consider pretty damn good for
protein intake the RDA is 0.8 grams per
kilogram per day in in the United States
I think that pretty damn good is 1.2 to
1.6 uh that is a protein intake where I
might say you know what it's possible
that we are not fully fully fully
optimizing your gains but we are getting
the Lion's Share of gains that are
currently accessible to you and what
gains are accessible to you that's going
to be determined by your genetics your
response to training and the nuts and
bolts of your current training program
uh now for the fat free Mass equivalent
uh I would say that that would be
roughly 1.5 to 2 Grand 1.5 to 2 grams
per kilogram of fat free mass now the
optimal range I still agree I I
absolutely concur if you said my goal is
to leave no gains on the table and I I
want to leave no doubt I want to be
certain that I am in the optimal range
and I'm not under eating my protein I
still think the optimal range going by
total body mass is 1.6 to 2.2 grams per
kilogram per day and if we scale that to
fat free Mass I'd say that's more in the
range of like 2 to 2.75
grams of protein per kilogram of fat
free mass and one additional note since
you brought up vegans this was actually
already in the outline if you are
totally vegan so no eggs no Dairy no
meat no fish all that stuff and you're
very adamant about supporting fat free
mass accretion or retaining it during a
cut I do think you know we've talked
about previously uh on the show there's
research indicating if you're getting
1.6 grams per kilogram per day or above
um per kilogram of total body mass if
you're getting into that standard
optimal range vegan diets versus
omnivorous diets seem to have similar
effects on hypertrophy even as a vegan I
can acknowledge as total protein intake
starts getting lower and lower the
differences between a vegan diet and an
omnivorous diet and how they support
hypertrophy the differences become more
apparent yeah and so what that means is
it's it's very nice as a vegan to say
whatever just eat enough protein and
you're good get over 1.6 and you're fine
if you are going to give yourself a
little bit of slack and say I don't need
to push to 1.6 I realize based on the
literature I'm not necessarily losing
that much if I settle a little lower
than that I would still say like either
try to get like at least 1.4 ish if
you're totally vegan or just be really
really adamant about making sure that
you have some really high-ish quality
vegan proteins in your diet so make sure
you've got plenty of you know soy based
proteins
mycoprotein-based proteins maybe you
spend a little more time making sure
that you have complementary protein
sources you just want to have a kind of
a heightened sense of awareness if
you're on a totally vegan diet and you
are falling below that 1.6 threshold if
you're on a
ovalacto vegetarian diet and you're
still getting whey and Greek yogurt and
eggs and all that stuff
you're essentially
you're basically an omnivore when it
comes to to protein quality you know so
uh that little caveat there I'd say only
applies to pretty strict vegans
all right so I think that does it uh
like I said though basically just trying
to make one point and that is I'm not
disputing the kind of standard optimal
range for protein intake but I do think
people should uh when they really hate
getting up into that that higher range
of protein intake it's worth
readdressing the question of how much do
I lose when I settle at 1.4 instead of
1.6 and the answer based on the
literature is simply not that much
absolutely I and I think that that's a
good a good just kind of like
generalizable thing to keep in mind like
if
um
if someone is saying that something is
is good for you and you should do it and
it's going to improve your gains
um
it is worth asking
to what extent does this seem to be
generalizably true or you know is it
just like yeah one or two studies kind
of supporting this thing and uh like
what what is the effect magnitude like
if if something does seem to be net
beneficial but you know it doesn't like
the actual magnitude of the effect seems
to be quite small then it's just a
question of of how much is that worth it
to you like I think this comes up in
discussions of supplements pretty
frequently like you know the uh like
creatine in particular seems to be quite
good and then once you go down from
there you know there's there's a variety
of things that might have a beneficial
effect on on strength endurance or any
number of like acute training variables
um generally the impact isn't all that
large and so if if someone approached
all of those things with kind of the
same mindset that it seems a lot of
people approach protein with of damn
like I definitely have to get one get to
1.6 grams per kilo or I'm leaving a lot
on the table
I don't think most people apply that
same sort of thought to supplements
where it's like well I mean it seems
like it seems like citrulline malate has
a small effect so like I definitely need
to take that before every workout beta
alanine that's hard to say may have a
small effect definitely need to take
that before every workout like if if
that is the sort of uh uh reasoning
process you go through you you're going
to wind up being on the hook for doing
all sorts of [ __ ] that may be beneficial
but probably only has a relatively small
benefit
um so yeah if you don't go down that
road for any number of other topics
probably not worth going down that road
and getting like that obsessive when it
comes to protein
um and if you do find yourself going
down that road on a lot of different
topics pretty frequently I I would just
uh implore you to take a step back and
ask yourself
how much is this actually going to
affect me and is is the cost worth the
anticipated benefit yeah and you know I
will say it's one thing I remember when
I was younger and you know especially
with supplements I intuitively
understood that the effects would be
small but I had fun yeah and I wasn't
doing anything dangerous you know I was
I wasn't taking any you know dubious you
know well I you potentially were
the supplement industry back then well
had a pretty big issue with uh heavy
metal contamination that we didn't find
out about until after the fact that's
true
yeah but you know I was I was selecting
you weren't knowingly doing anything
that was risky I was selecting products
that if manufactured correctly had low
risk profiles right so yes it was there
was minimal skin in the game it was oh
I'm gonna have some fun and see if beta
alanine does something for me you know
the cost was not super cheap for a
college student but cheap enough to
swing it you know so there's two
different ways that people approach this
like are you sweating over all the small
details because you're very worried and
concerned
or are you exploring the small details
because you're curious and inquisitive
and you enjoy that exploration process I
view those as two very very different
things and so I try not to stifle people
who want to try to mess around with some
of the smaller stuff and kind of say oh
wow that was nice I think I'm getting
something out of it
um you know versus like yeah if you are
just in a constant state of dread
because you think you need to increase
your protein intake by 0.3 grams per
kilogram per day
you really got to revisit that yeah yeah
and also I just want to mention that was
a really clear shot across the bow that
I did receive and uh and certainly
recognize uh just unnecessarily calling
out citrulline malate which I was the
first author of A meta-analysis on it
and calling out beta alanine I was the
first author of the issn position stand
on that
um so I feel like you there was clearly
some Jabs happening there and I will
acknowledge them but I won't respond to
them
yeah okay
um yeah that's fine all right you can
tell that uh I I was I was debating
whether I also wanted to to take a small
shot at nitrate or uh caffeine versus
coffee yeah
um what are what are some other things
you've looked at those those are the
four that come to mind for me oh man I
mean we did some uh some like uh special
carbohydrate supplementation like the
high molecular weight stuff protein
stuff
um you know I mean some adaptogens throw
those in the mix I mean yeah but you
know when it comes to those papers like
you can kind of tell what got me into
research and what I viewed as a fun
project you know I was just like oh I've
been messing around with this stuff for
three years I'd like to research it you
know yeah uh all right so I think that
does it for this episode of The Stronger
by science podcast as always thanks so
much for joining us and we will be back
soon with another episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast if you enjoyed the
podcast be sure to sign up for our free
newsletter to get concise breakdowns of
relevant research as well as 28 free
training programs for all skill levels
and all schedules we hate spam just as
much as you do so we'll only email you
when we have something really
interesting to share with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbuyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]